parents across the country are ditching
strollers and strapping on baby carriers
studies show the baby carrier industry
was expected to grow four and a half
percent between 2010 and 2020 too that's
partly because celebrities like Ryan
Reynolds Natalie Portman John Legend
Madonna
Tony the couple are reviving this method
all CBS this morning Saturday co-host
Dana Jacobson spoke to parents who to
find out how babywearing is making a
comeback fighting time to exercise is
hard for any mom so more Caldwell
incorporates her children into her
workout we have waited bests here at the
gym that I see people wear so I figured
it wasn't that different than that mine
just makes noise and you know tries to
ask for snacks while I'm working out the
Minneapolis mom started babywearing
not just as an extra physical challenge
but out of necessity it was a way for me
to feel really safe and to feel like he
was safe just after her son Benjamin was
born he was hospitalized for almost 5
weeks how much time were you able to
spend with him in the hospital I held
him in my arms every second that I
wasn't asleep which made it really hard
to come home and just put him down so it
seemed natural yeah carried on even when
she was 9 months pregnant with her
daughter Ava people thought it was
seemed really difficult but honestly I
felt like it I had about 30 pounds in
front and 30 pounds and back and I got
bigger and bigger and kept doing the
same things and it worked out really
well for me
Caldwell is just one of many parents
ditching strollers and strapping their
babies into carriers for the hands-free
benefits how you doing baby like Oregon
dad Tom powers who where's his daughter
Sylvan while he door knocks for local
candidates as part of his job I think a
guy with the baby is a little bit more
friendly seeming but also it's just for
practical purposes we've got two kids
and we kind of have to divide and
conquer or la mom Ashley right who wears
her daughter as she pole dances for
fitness if I always concede it to my
baby's cries and stop everything I was
doing to do that you know what
not getting and guys so we just spin
around and it's like a little
merry-go-round for them babywearing
groups have sprung up across the United
States where like-minded babywearing
parents can rub elbows
[Applause]
we don't have a similar parenting style
and we've all want to keep our babies
close and connected
it's basically for freedom I mean you
can wear a baby and you can do
everything you need to do
studies show that baby wearing can
improve maternal physical health bonding
and reduce infant crying but after 17
deaths were reported from 2003 to 2006
teen the federal government unveiled new
safety standards for baby carriers
including requiring warning labels to
keep infants faces visible to avoid
suffocation the biggest mistake that
parents make us to try and find one
carrier to do it all industry expert
joanna McNeely says it's about reading
the instructions and practicing without
the baby baby carriers are very safe in
fact I would say they're probably the
safest place you could put the baby as
for more Caldwell she says baby wearing
is empowering do you ever worry about
their safety when you're carrying them
doing any of these things no I try
really hard to not do things that would
be unsafe in my book to me it feels
safer to have them right next to me and
knowing where they are and have my hands
for you to do what I need to do for CBS
this morning Dana Jacobson Minneapolis
so the baby carrying phenomena is
amazing because the birth rate is not
going up but sales of those things are
and I use it I have an older son so to
play catch with him while having the
baby on me yeah it's doable
just little bracing of the head with the
glove as you throw the ball back
otherwise we did it with our kids
although I didn't do pole dancing with
us